it is time for audience questions first
one today comes in via voicemail from
across the pond let's take a listen to
this one and then we will answer it
hey David this is Oliver from Germany I
was wondering if you have any homeless
folks in your circle sentence I was
watching a lot of your interviews you
conducted over the years mmm I don't
know I wasn't just wondering this like
who ever started like to get in deeper
touch with any of those Christian people
on a human level even though you would
disagree and you would see them as a
homophobe it's you kind of understood
their point and kind of got along with
them I don't know I guess you get what I
mean
that was just one thank you yes got it
okay so listen
are there homophobes in my circle of
friends and by the way he said am I ever
in touch with Christians like that and
you can be homophobic and not Christian
in fact my biggest falling-out was with
a friend who is not Christian and was
homophobic and for about two years I
didn't speak to him because we had a
falling out when I said I said something
really innocuous like I'm going to a
wedding and he said oh is it a gay
wedding and I said no it's not it's
actually because I think he thought
there was somebody a friend of mine who
was gay was getting married sometime
soon I said no in fact it's in a state
that doesn't even have gay marriage at
the time and he said oh good because I
don't believe in that and I said what do
you mean you don't believe in that he
says I think it's wrong and I think it
shouldn't be allowed and this was a
relatively close friend and it sort of
came out of left field for me and I said
I'm not friends with people who are
intolerant in that way I have a lot of
gay friends and it would be completely
inappropriate and embarrassing for me to
be around you and them and you let slip
an opinion like that that so I'm sorry I
can't really be in touch with you
Wow and we didn't talk for years and
years later he came back to me and said
listen you know I'm sorry about that I
was ignorant I was uninformed my views
have changed and now this individual has
has many gay friends and I have no
reason to think that they
hold the same views ironically you kind
of broke up with him in a way over the
topic of gay marriage in a sense you
could say that in a sense you could say
that but we are back together now which
is a nice thing so do I have homophobes
in my social circles not anybody who's
close to me right I mean there's
certainly people who I might be involved
in business stuff with that I don't know
that well or I'm part of a group that is
involved I'm like part of a poker group
in Boston I don't know the political
beliefs of the other people there that
there are LGBT individuals in the poker
group it's also possible that there are
homophobes in the poker group but it
doesn't come up you know what I mean
yeah what about people in your social
circles that maybe say that's gay when
they mean to say that's stupid or not
really use the F word that sometimes
attributed negative homosexual not
really no those people have basically
fallen off I mean I think in the few
years after high school I was still sort
of around people that I that I was
around merely because we shared common
highschool friends but now that my
social circle is much more cleanly
defined by who I want to spend time with
not who's sort of hanging on as a friend
of a friend of a friend type of thing
not really I did go as somebody
mentioned the Christian thing I did go
to northern rural Indiana a couple weeks
ago and while the topic of gay marriage
didn't come up there is no doubt that a
lot of the people I was around would
there absolutely believe that
homosexuality is a sin gay marriage
shouldn't be legal etc but these are not
people I associate with in any kind of
regular pattern yeah I mean the best of
my knowledge there are no homophobes in
my social circles but maybe so when I
was you know 11 12 years old I was I
wonder if that has to do with the age
that you are I mean those kids tend to
be kind of ruthless and mean I think had
part of it also deals with where you
were going to middle school or just the
time that we're living in right yeah you
know 10 or so years ago makes a big
difference I think now especially
because the same-sex marriage is
legalized across the whole country it's
a lot more accepted now than it was I do
think that in general being in
Massachusetts if you are a progressive
minded individual and you live in the
most parts of Massachusetts are quite
liberal although not not so much where
Pat grew up you're less likely
mathematically to be around homophobes
right because you're talking about the
first state with legal gay marriage and
we're talking about a much more
more progressive state but that I'm not
painting it as a panacea right I mean of
course there are homophobes in
Massachusetts but to the best of my
knowledge I am NOT closely associating
with any homophobe now if you grew up in
Provincetown you probably wouldn't find
any homophobes cuz they have left
already right why would they go to the
gay vacation capital of New England if
they were homophobic but you know what
there is a kind of local Cape Cod
population that is a little more
conservative you know but but you would
think they probably would have moved out
of Provincetown proper and maybe into
some of those surrounding towns or
something like that
Barnstable or Hyannis sure yeah maybe a
little further out